[Applause]
[Music]
it may be getting colder in your part of
the world so take a lesson from Sonic
and keep running to keep yourself warm
or drive around in a warm car or go
straight to hell Wow okay that last one
sounded a lot nicer on paper let me make
it up to you by going over some of the
hottest new releases dropping this week
by this point pretty much everyone knows
what Sonic games are all about but sonic
forces is looking to mix things up in a
few ways
first the classic and modern hedgehogs
both returned from generations letting
them run through 2d and 3d levels
respectively joining them is well
whoever you want to join them for the
first time you can build your own
character to race through Sonic levels
and depending on the base you choose
your custom hero will have special
abilities to use along the way you can
try it for yourself on ps4 Xbox one PC
and Nintendo switch on Tuesday November
7th if you want to see it in action
before then we've got gameplay of both
regular old Sonic and our custom
character up on GameSpot let's slow
things down with the careful samurai
combat of neo complete addition is much
more than just a PC port of the souls
like game from earlier this year it
includes the original adventure plus all
the expansions and an exclusive valve
Kabuto helmets it offers the same option
to toggle between action and movie modes
but with 4k support if you go the
cinematic route if you missed out on
this tense action game back in spring
you'll get your chance on PC on Tuesday
the 7th and now back to the fast games
with Need for Speed payback much like
Sonic you probably already know what the
Need for Speed games are all about but
this entry takes big influences from The
Fast and Furious movies with an open
world ready for what publisher EA calls
action driving you've got three drivers
with different skills behind the wheel
and you'll have to use them all to take
down the house a cartel that runs the
underworld in Fortune Valley you can
start your engines of ps4 Xbox one and
PC on
November 10th fingers crossed for some
actual fast and furious DLC down the
road you don't even one that girl oh did
you think the 3ds was done Mario Party
the top 100 is here to prove you wrong
there have been quite a few games in the
Mario Party series but this collection
brings together all of the best
minigames over the years with new
options to keep things moving faster and
thanks to Download Play all it takes is
one copy to play local multiplayer with
your friends you can get the party
started in the US on Friday the 10th and
now for a very different handheld
Nintendo experience doom is making its
way to the switch which means you can
visit Mars and slay demons anywhere this
is the same game that came to other
consoles last year with its competitive
multiplayer available as a free separate
download though it is worth mentioning
that the game deliberately runs at 30
frames per second Doom tears into the
Nintendo switch on the 10th and those
are some of the hottest games we'll be
playing this week as always remember
that release dates are based on retailer
listings and are subject to change
thanks for watching guys and I'll be
back with another dose of new releases
next Sunday
you